[تصفيق]
صباح الخير يا شباب ازيكم انا مبسوط جدا
ان انا معكم النهارده في جامعه المنصوره
لان انا نصي من المنصور والدتي الله
يرحمها
فانا امي من طلخه اللي فيكم
قاعده انتم كلكم
عارفين طلخه بيقولوا عليها ايه مش هنقولها
عشان الحاجات دي متسجله
تمام فانا نصي الحلو من امي الله يرحمها
من المنصوره
وجد امي
هو كانت بره ما كانش عمل جامع كان عمل
محكمه المنصوره اللي هو المبنى القديم
بتاع محكمه المنصوره
وانا احد اول مصنع عملته في حياتي كان تبع
محافظه الدقهليه في العصافره المطريه
الدقهليه فانا المنصوره واهل المنصوره
وطلبت المنصوره قريبين القلب جدا
انا ما سمعتش الحقيقه هو قدم قدمني ازاي
يعني بس احنا بناء على اللي احنا هنتكلم
فيه النهارده انا هاخدكم كده في رحله
ما بين اختلاف اجيال بينها وبين بعضها
وهنتكلم انا بشتغل في حاجات كتيره وعندي
بيزنس كتيره يعني من ضمن الحاجات اللي
بشتغل فيها بشتغل في الصناعات الغذائيه
وانا عندي اباوت فتقدروا ترتبهوني شيف
فيها انا بطبخ حلو فهتلاقوا في النص كده
ايه لان احنا بنعمل ريسك
في الحدوته ففيه بعض الكلمات كده هتقول لي
بيقول لكم ايه في الرسم
المهم
اختلاف الاجيال انا شمس دخلت الكليه سنه
وعنديزنس من سنه 90 وعملت من الهندسه
بعد ما اشتغلت في الهندسه لمده سنه كنت
بشتغل في البي ام ده كمهندس
فانا هاخدكم كده في البريزنتيشن في شيء من
الرحله هي مش بتمثلش حياتي الشخصيه انها
بتمثل الفكره
[تصفيق]
دايما عندنا بيبقى كده اباوت القديم
والجديد ففي ناس بيبقى عندها حنين للقديم
وناس بتبقى شايفه ان الجديد ده من الناس
القديمه
ان دي حاجه جديده فبيرفضوها
فلو خدنا مجال زي مجال الغناء
ما اعرفش انتوا ده مين ولا لا ده محمد عبد
الوهاب
بعد محمد عبد الوهاب جاء عبد الحليم عبد
الحليم حافظ اللي فيكم يعرف عبد الحليم
لما جه في الوقت بتاع محمد عبد الوهاب كان
شكل جديد من الاغنيه فكان في رفض العبد
الحليم
وبعدين جه استاذ احمد عدويه
احمد عدويه اترفض انه يتسجل
والحركه بتاعته دي كان الناس بيشوفوها
اللي هو بعض الناس دلوقتي مثلا كده
شوفوا ايه ان دي حاجه مش لطيفه احنا بنحدر
بالذوق العالي دلوقتي احمد عدويه بقى هو
الاصاله والطرب الاصيل وحاجه
وبعدين جاء الهضبه تمام
هضبه جه في فتره المغني كان بيقف يغني
قدام مايك كده عليه الحجار واشباه ده واحد
طلع بقى بيتنطط على المسرح قال لي كده
فهنا الفكره القديمه
هنحكي حدوته دي شركه
وهنخش في الحدوته في التكنولوجيا
فدي شركه فيها ناس قديمه دخل عليهم
التكنولوجيا
فالراجل العجوز اللي زي حالاتي كده
راح واخد ايه نفسه على جنب وهو متعود انه
يكتب بالورقه والقلم
فبالنسبه له القصه بقت ايه ايه الكمبيوتر
والحاجات دي فبقى في رفض للجديد
قديم جديد ازاي الواحد بيتواكب مع اللي
بيحصل جديد
وبعدين
متمثل في زينه
زينه بقى البنت الفركوكه اللي هي ايه عاشت
في عالم التكنولوجيا
فبتبتدي ايه اي حاجه بسلك كده تخش تصلح
الكمبيوتر تبتدي تخش على السوشيال ميديا
معها فبقت بالنسبه للراجل القديم ده
اختراع
بس كانت في نفس الوقت بتحبب الناس في فكره
التكنولوجيا ان هم شايفين انها بتؤدي اداء
حسن فهذا المجال
ابتدى يحصل نوع من
الفجوه الرقميه ما بين جديد وما بين قديم
ازاي ده الراجل القديم ده هيبتدي يتعامل
مع ما هو جديد وازاي الجديد ده
نقطه مهمه قوي مع القديم
فسكت بقى لنا عايشه في جلباب ابي لا ده
راجل قديم ده بيفكر بطريقه مختلفه وده
يمكن ايه بتواجهوهم مثلا مع ابهاتكم مع
امهاتكم مع الدكتور بتاع الجامعه لا وكان
الناس دي جايه من عالم خارجي ففي فكره
بس لو عملنا الكلام ده على مستوى فبيحصل
المستقبل قيمته
والفيوتشر قدامكم
بس الوصول للفيوتشر ده له اليات
النصيحه ان احنا نمسك بالاليات بالريسيفي
بالوصفه بالخلطه بتاعه النجاح للمستقبل
والمستقبل حلو
بس في تحديات
وهنتكلم في عجاله كده عن التحديات في
التكنولوجيا
فانا واحد من الناس
مريت بمراحل متعدده في التكنولوجيا
من ايام ما دخلت الجامعه ما كانش فيه نت
الحصول على المعلومه كان صعب جدا احنا في
الكليه انا كان مشروع التحرك بتاعي مشروع
بتاعه طاحونه
ما كانش فيه في مكتبه كليه الهندسه جامعه
عين شمس واحد عن طواحين الهوى فكنا عندنا
اتفاقيه مع الجامعه الامريكيه فكنا بنروح
المكتبه بتاعت الجامعه الامريكيه اللي هي
مكانها دلوقتي ان احنا نقدر نتعاون معهم
علشان نوصل للمعلومه فالوصول للمعلومه كان
صعب
دلوقتي انت عندكم المهمه ان المعلومات بقى
الاتاحه لها سهل
فاشتغلوا على كده خدوا الفرصه وما
تفوتوهاش بس خدوا الفرصه بكثير من العمق
في الحصول على المعلومه
النجاح يكمن في التفاصيل ما تاخدوش الحاجه
من على الوش
خدوا تجربتكم الشخصيه
ولا خابه من استشار استشيروا اللي اكبر
منكم بس تجربتكم بنفسكم
وخلوا عندكم الحلم
لان لو الواحد ما عندوش حلم او ما عندوش
امل هتبقى الدنيا مش احلى حاجه في الدنيا
فانا عندي كده كود حطو حتى حطه عندي في
لينك
ده كان في فيلم كده هوب ميبي ذا بيست اوف
فخلو عندكم امل وتشبسوا به مهما كانت
التحديات
في التكنولوجي وده حاصل اليومين دول مين
منكم بيتعامل مع
تمام
مين منكم بيتعامل مع فكره الذكاء
الاصطناعي
تمام
الذكاء الاصطناعي ده جاي
وجاي بعنف
انا في الثانويه العامه كنا ممنوع نخش
امتحان الثانويه العامه معنا كالكوليتر
فاحنا مرينا بمراحل معينه للتكنولوجيا في
وقت ظهور الكالكوليتر كان في جامد قوي ان
الكالكوليتور ده هيخلي الناس مخها يتوقف
عن التفكير
اللي حصل حصل جزء من هذا الكلام بس الناس
بقت بتروح انها تعمل
فحصل تطور
فالارتفيشنز جاي بعنف لازم نبقى واخدين
بالنا وهو جاي ان احنا نستخدمه بالطريقه
الصح ويبقى في جزء الانساني وده في
التجربه بتاعه الشركه الحدوته اللي احنا
بنحكيها
ان الاعتماد على التكنولوجي ساعدنا بس
لازم يبقى في الجزء الانساني في التعامل
مع الناس يبقى في
ما نبعتش للناس في العيد اس ام اس
نرفع سماعه التليفون عشان بيبقى باين في
تونس الصوت اذا كنت انا مبسوط ولا حاجه
وابعتلوش واتساب
فالجزء الانساني الجزء اللي بيكمل
التكنولوجيا التكنولوجي لو هي لوحدها بس
هتبقى الدنيا دراي
فلازم نقوي الكلام ده بالجزء الانساني وده
اللي حصل في الشركه
وفي سلايد مش موجوده بس مش اشكال
فاللي انا بقوله بالنسبه لكم ما تاخدوش
حاجه من على الوش
خلوا عندكم حلمكم واشتغلوا عليه بس
التكنولوجي قادمه
فاللي مش هيبتدي يتعاون معها دلوقتي هيبقى
زي من 25 سنه اللي ما بيعرفش يتعامل مع
الكمبيوتر
تعاملوا معها بس تعامله معها برفق وليس من
منطلق الكسل انا ممكن اتعامل مع
التكنولوجيا دي انها كسل دي هتعمل لي
البريزنتيشن بتاعتي هتعمل لي الواجب بتاعي
او الهوم ورك بتاعي فخلاص الحل السهل
موجود قدامي اروح اجيب
مش ده الصح قوي من وجهه نظري التي تحتمل
الصواب وتحتمل الخطا
اجتهدوا واعملوا الهوم ورك بتاعكم علشان
تحققه
دي زي ما بنعمل كده ايه الاكل ممكن مثلا
لو دخلتوا على النت هتلاقوا فيه
عشره الاف واحد بيعملوا كبده اسكندر
كل واحد ممكن بيعملها بطريقه
وممكن تبقى العشره الاف وصفه فيها 5000
وصفه حلوين قوي فكل واحد فيكم يعمل بتاعته
بطريقته
بس ايه يبص على الناس التانيين بيعملوا
يوسف ازاي عشان ما يبقاش ما يطلق عليه في
العالم ما يبقاش ميه تو لو انا زيي زي
غيري ابقى متميز ليه
تمام
العناصر
بتاعه النجاح اول حاجه الهارد ورك
مش بكسل تاني حاجه الدخول في التفاصيل
النجاح في التفاصيل
تالت حاجه ان انا اخد الريسك بس يبقى
كالكوليت ما ابقاش متهور يبقى حساب او او
مخاطره محسوب
رابع حاجه
والسبات على اللي انا بعمله
ما تغيرش من
بيميل للشمال بسرعه
خامس حاجه ان انا عمري ما اقدم الندم حاجه
وحشه قوي فعمري ما اندم على مجهود انعم اي
مجهود انا عملته هستفيد به بشكل او باخر
احنا اخبار الوقت ايه انت ناسيه ما فيش اي
حاجه
فاضل لي قد ايه
ماشي
اوكي
عمركوا ما تبكوا على اللبن المسكوب لو
تعرفوا عن ايه الجمله دي
طبعا وقع مني شويه لبن وانا راجل لبان
فاقعد اعيط على اللاب خلاص
اروح اجيب باتش تاني واعمل سيلز جديد
ومعيطش على اللبن اللي رف فدائما التعلم
له تمن
ده يبقى وقت مجهود فلوس وتفرق
ادفعوا التمن بنفس راضيه علشان توصلوا
او تحققه كبده الاسكندراني بتاعتكم كل
واحد فيكم بطريقته بوصفه النجاح بتاعته
شكل ليكم وسعيد بلقائكم